i don't i don't really have good nipples
yeah i've never heard a guy
self-conscious about his nipples at all
i mean it's just they're there i've
never even thought about mine mine are
just there ladies seem to love them
[Laughter]
and they told me that this was you know
this was representative of conan's you
know
tuna inside what i want you to do is i
know what to do
this is big for you obviously they knew
okay i knew about this thing in high
school
my son came to me about i would say like
about a month ago he came to me and he
said dad what's pornography and i was
like oh well you're like we're gonna
we're gonna have yeah let me show you uh
no
he said what's pornography and i said oh
well you must have heard that word at
school and we're going to talk about it
as holy talk where did you hear the word
and he said on a simpsons episode that
you wrote and
how are you how are you having a good
summer so far yes so
many penises
okay
which is also referred to as the sexual
chakra
um and that's also self-explanatory but
for instance like if someone has um an
issue with like premature ejaculation
that would show up in your sacral chakra
who have you been talking to
we used to go down in the chair and like
do like stimulate sex
wait a minute i feel like you're having
sex you go like this
i was gonna say so that's what queen
elizabeth is doing
um the speed of a man's ejaculate i just
learned what
it's 27 miles per hour which is also 27
miles per hour yes 27 miles an hour yes
and that's impressive it's also the
actually if you can get it a mile yeah
fill up that whole hour
the hormone clicking you're like
no
i'm still as a as an a as a as a
middle-aged man i'm still constantly
reaching for boob all the time but not
your mom what's that not your mom you
know you know
look at that build arms like this oh
fantastic
cover
are you okay betty
i'm getting better
[Applause]
like a tap on the ball might be as
painful as a punch in the ball is this
true
i'm glad you asked
a punch in the ball is worse okay is
much worse he's wrong okay i've been
tapped on the balls many times
i find it pleasurable yeah
well maybe uh you'd like to see him i
was on the cover too i don't know if you
saw this but check it out
what a flat butt i i never knew that
that was
you know what the guard says if it gives
you a flat ass he's going to give you a
big old
i just touch your boob
what
roll that back i didn't see
that rule attacks
[Applause]
roll it back
how are you an exhibitionist you said
you just like you like to
get attention any way you could i said
something once that's gonna stay with me
i used to lift up my skirt and
i feel like as a three-year-old though i
mean it's hot it's like a child thing to
do and it's uh she was three shut up
you're like ow like it was three i had
to wear merkin do you know what a merkin
is
andy knows i know what american is
it's a wig for your lady bits
this interview's over
i would be with a guy with a micro penis
obvious i really would thank you wow
well you just you just saved that man's
life
who cares no don't put a camera on him i
see a camera moving
don't put a camera on micro penis man
for god's sake when i the reason i the
way that i met simon was they asked me
to be a guest judge focus conan to be um
dancer
finally we'll be real here for a second
i'm speaking up you didn't think i was
going to look down there
[Applause]
katy perry finger banged my cleavage it
was a weird night
she's very mature
this was an unplanned moment and i want
to stay right here
always been a ginger do you like being a
ginger i do but we're a dying breed
apparently yes i keep hearing that we
should mate to save the species
[Applause]
why are you backing off of that right
away
i haven't done anything
but okay uh they didn't ask me to but
i'm naked so much in it i wanted one
because it felt like a little fur bikini
but i
[Laughter]
i
i feel like such a perv now
tell me more about the fur bikini
i definitely think i would sleep with
tom brady i'm that excited i don't know
why you wouldn't yeah i don't know i'd
do it just to get at that gizelle yeah
that and that that would be the way yeah
what do you mean
with tom brady but looking over it
i'll be over there in a minute
[Music]
comments that they wanted like oh we
want her to be
more bosomy uh that was a bigger heart
bigger heart yeah but that's
i'm talking about frustrated nerds
online i think you look absolutely
stunning and i'm here to take dinner any
time
thank you